if you're looking to prevent a hangover  the next morning then avoid diet mixers  that's a prize you I know a lot of  people have this thing where they think  sugar is what causes the hangover the  next day it's actually not true number  one because fructose is actually helpful  in speeding up the metabolism of alcohol  so you mix it with orange juice or  grapefruit juice and you're actually  gonna clear the alcohol from your system  a lot faster number two when you drink  alcohol it kind of stuns your liver  where it can't make sugar from scratch  for energy for you so if you don't give  it any other energy you're gonna feel  pretty lousy in the morning so look stay  away from the diet sodas go for some  nice juice mixers or at least regular  soda mixers and I promise you you will  feel better in the morning  I'm dr. Keller and there's a hangover  tip for you